[Music]
[Applause]
chris bald inbound
looking in for booker
who takes a three no good tucker with
the rebound
the suns are not gonna foul
it's been a 50 year journey
wisconsin we've got a room at the top of
the world tonight
the milwaukee bucks are nba
champions let the celebration begin
wtmj the bucks radio network
and the man making the call ted davis
the bucks play by play announcer and
paulie picked this up with a tribute to
a shout out to tom petty in the uh
lyrics there room at the top and ted
joins us on the program
did you have it scripted ted not really
i mean i had an idea i wanted to connect
50 years to now
and you know i'm such a big tom petty
fan
he's the only celebrity who when he died
it really hit me emotionally because
i love his music love his lyrics they're
so simple and evocative
and i wanted to work that in somehow
because hey the bucks do have a room at
the top of the world tonight
and as tom petty said i ain't coming
down
what did you think of it it felt like a
coronation with
65 000 outside uh packed house inside
what what was that feeling like for you
trying to set the scene on radio
well eight years ago um i was doing
games for the bucks when
ryannis was a rookie and middleton had
just arrived from detroit
and that team won 15 games and you had
trouble getting 10 000 people in the
arena
so uh to see where the bucks are now i
mean let's face it for a long time
milwaukee was nba siberia to a lot of
players they didn't want to come here it
was a cold weather city
it had an aging arena they had one in a
long time
and now you look at where they are with
that beautiful arena selling out every
game
the deer district out there had i don't
know how many people 60 65
000 people just standing outside the nba
is now a great viable market and
giannis's presence
at the age of 26 27 going into his prime
i think is going to ensure that
milwaukee is now a destination for
players who want to chase a ring
because they know they can win here the
entire perception
of the franchise and in some ways the
city has changed
when did you realize how good how great
giannis could be
remember a game or a moment probably in
his third season jason kidd was the
coach
and the the team really wasn't going
anywhere may have been his fourth season
and kid just tossed the keys to him and
said
you play point guard for a while and
that's when he started having triple
doubles
i remember he had a triple-double the
night kobe bryant retired
well it was the year he retired it was
his last game in milwaukee
and after that game jason kidd set up a
private meeting off the bucks locker
room just kidd
giannis and kobe bryant and he honestly
had a triple-double that night the bucks
had won the game
and kobe bryant said to giannis you have
the talent to be as good as you want to
be
now do you want to work for it and i
think that
little light bulb above giannis's head
saying
man if kobe thinks i can do it i can do
it now i think he had that work
work ethic within him anyway but we all
need a little motivation right a jump
starter
something to kick us i think that did
and from that point on
we've seen giannis grow into this
full-blown battering ram mode that
is an mvp in the league and an mvp in
the finals what was the mood like when
the suns went up 2-0
um i don't think anybody panicked they
they knew they were coming home
they had played very well at home they
had been down
o2 in the brooklyn series and came back
and won the two home games to
flip the script to make it a 2-2 series
and they did it again
this group had some scars from the last
two seasons
where they were up 2-0 against toronto
in 2019 in the eastern conference finals
and lost four in a row
last year they lost focus when they went
into the bubble and they got bounced out
by
miami in a gentleman's sweep they had
been the top seed
the best record in the nba and it wasn't
good enough i think those scars were
there at the beginning
and there was no panic on this team they
knew that they were good enough to win
and they just set about doing the
business of making it happen
and you have to learn from your
suffering from your disappointments and
i think this team
did when giannis was uh
drafted he came over and then milwaukee
decided i think the
gm at the time john hammond brought his
family
to milwaukee to make him more
comfortable but before that giannis was
sending money home
during his rookie season he does mention
his mom
a lot what role has she played
oh she's big in his life for a lot of
reasons
i mean they were very poor in greece
when they immigrated from
nigeria they couldn't get citizenship
they were living off the books
his mom and his dad worked really hard
to make
life as good as it could be in those
circumstances
and he remembers that he's very strong
on family he's very
loyal to them there's a there's a story
that's been told but i don't think
people really realize how close giannis
was to not
living his nba dream when he came over
in his rookie season
it took a long time to get the paperwork
done to get his parents out of greece
and the buck's ownership senator herb
cole at the time
was working through the state department
to get it done but the greek
government was not cooperating and they
you have three
chances to get your family out so they
tried the first time
greece said no they tried the second
time greece said no
now this is the third time and this went
all the way to the top of the state
department i think john kerry
was the secretary of state at the time
and giannis has said that if he had not
gotten his family out of greece at that
point
he was going to go back and play in
europe he wasn't going to play in the
nba
this might have never happened but they
got it done they got his parents over
here
now he's a two-time mvp he's going into
this
super max contract next year that will
change his life it's generational money
and it's a great story phoenix sons
would like to recheck that paperwork of
uh giannis
just just saying there ted but uh hey
congratulations it's uh
not just players who suffer through this
it's certainly
you know people like you who are there
every single night you got to show up at
the building when you're winning 15
games people forget about that everybody
would love to be in the position you had
last night it sounded great
and uh congrats ted well thank you i had
a veteran when i got into the league in
my first year he said you know we don't
we don't get paid just to do the good
game
so you got to do the bad ones but when
you have a good one
you want to savor it yeah so thank you
but if
the bucks had lost would you have gone
with free fallen or
breakdown by tom peter tom
probably free falling yeah that's what
it would have felt like well congrats
get some sleep ted thanks for joining us
all right thank you dan bike all right
that's ted davis bucks play by play
announcer